[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
hi we are aegon games and what you have
just seen is the first glimpse of our
upcoming game called name final form
final form is an action-packed epic
sci-fi
fps in which you are a female formed
humanoid machine
on a space mission with no return
at the heart of the game is a mystery an
alien words to explore but also an
adrenaline-fueled combat
in final form it's all about the freedom
and power of movement being a machine
unrestrained by human weaknesses
there are numerous abilities and gadgets
that come with your robotic body so you
can give yourself away to the fantasy of
becoming an unstoppable
cybernetic goddess blazing away in a
spectacular ballad of destruction
raeken is located in warsaw poland with
additional team members located all over
the world
the studio was founded and is managed
entirely by game developers
since the success of ruiner we've grown
quite substantially
currently raikkonen is over 50 brilliant
game creators
and counting we are not a huge team
but what we love to do is to evolve
together with our projects
constantly finding smarter and better
ways
to achieve something truly unique
we build our work environment just like
we make games
aiming for the best results and personal
fulfillment
we strongly believe that the well-being
of team members needs to be taken care
of first
before we can pour all of that love into
a game
[Music]
the partnership with kosh media has been
very fruitful
and inspiring we're happy to be in the
avant-garde of the upcoming new label
we're looking forward to share more on
final form in the future
and in the meantime please enjoy the
rest of the show
and see you around
[Music]